la sologne il y a moins de deux siècles
l'homme transformer cet immense marécage
en un paysage boisé apprécié ainsi
l'homme invention de la nature invente à
son tour son environnement
c'est de cette réflexion qu'est née la
biennale d'art contemporain désir de
conjuguer art et paysage
jean et président de la biennale de
sologne
du 1er juillet au 20 septembre cinquante
artistes sur 20 sites privés ou
publiques proposent leur vision de
l'invention de la nature un des concepts
de la biennale un parcours d'art
environnementale on voit des oeuvres les
installations dans le paysage dans les
communes dans des propriétés privées
comme ici si le château du lude on est
des galeries partenaires aussi en art
contemporain que les gens ont commencé à
avoir depuis le 1er juillet sur plus de
40 km autour de chaumont sur tharonne 17
sites privés ou publics accueille les
oeuvres éphémères créées in situ ici
d'eau delaunay nous invite au paradoxe
entre matériaux espaces naturels
derrière il ya toujours madar de la dia
toujours une référence un peu écologique
dans mon travail
on m'a fait de leur pas la remarque mais
où est écrit avec du plastique dans la
nature
j'aime bien justement le contrat puisque
la nature ça peut être aussi veut dire
le jouet chocolat avec cette tension là
entre le trias béton qui sert à faire du
des bâtiments le plastique qui sert
enveloppes et des aliments ou la
nourriture et la laque ou le mettre dans
un cadre que deux mots différents et de
jouer avec la lumière sur tout ça aussi
là tu vas beaucoup surpris c'est le fait
de comment ça prend la lumière
chaumont sur tharonne et le centre n'est
pas logique de l'aguedal larry est
présent proposant une autre vision du
patrimoine solognot
nous voilà au coeur de la biennale avec
le jardin de sculptures mathieu corradi
nos philosophes critiques d'art a donné
carte blanche à 17 artistes reconnus ou
émergents
son inspiration l'asean cette nature
était en fait l'oeuvre de la main de la
manne humaine et donc ça m'a fait
beaucoup réfléchir sans les perturber ce
savant musulman marqué ces catégories
nature culture ne fonctionne exactement
comme je serai dans mon esprit avant 40
sculptures ou installations sont
présentés la thématique du lien entre
homme et nature apparaît au fil du
parcours harmonie ou discorde l'homme
chasse de plus en plus tous les rêves
qui a nourri ses yeux et c'est
d'installer son propre ordre dont la
licorne est absente
lionel sabatté c'est licorne vincent
mauger ces météorites xavier dambrine
son marcheur et son homme vortex les dix
sept artistes présents ont joué le jeu
d'une exploration de la nature
inscrivant leurs oeuvres comme un
prolongement fluides ou une dénonciation
ou la toute puissance de l'homme
la biennale de sologne est sans conteste
une exposition d'art contemporain de
très bon niveau accessible et gratuite
mais l'événement est aussi cet accès à
des paysages inattendus confidentiel que
propose le parcours d'art
environnementale quelques châteaux
domaine privé et villages sans partager
le goût de l'art au point d'ouvrir leurs
portes le temps de la biennale